(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(Cameron chuckling)
- Hi, everybody!
Right back at you, right back at you.
And obviously this is a
very special day for me
because I'm with my bestie, obviously.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(Cameron chuckling)
- Is everybody here, are
you guys with your besties?
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Yes!
Aren't besties the best?
Right?
(Cameron chuckling)
- I shudder to think where I
would be without my bestie.
- I know.
- And California is very
near and dear to our heart.
So this is a really amazing show for us
to do here in Premiere
Week, and I will say this,
now that I live in New York
and whenever I travel the country,
there's definitely one thing
that I crave more than anything else.
- I mean, all over the
world, you crave this.
- It's Battle of the Bites: Cali Tacos.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(Cameron chuckling)
(friends squealing)
- Oh my God, hi, everybody!
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Oh my goodness, look at you!
- Oh my God, I just heard
someone say taco and I showed up.
(audience laughing)
- So let's do this!
- Let's do it!
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Yes, sir.
- Thank you.
- Yes, please!
- All right, now we also have two viewers
and BFFs joining our judging panel.
So please welcome Kelsey and Malia.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Okay, since we're all besties, you guys,
you're gonna count as one vote,
and then we're all gonna vote as well.
We also have a Twitter vote happening.
So the restaurant with the most
votes will take home a prize
that'll give them something to taco about.
(Ross laughing)
By the way, Ross-
- Yeah, I'm so proud of you.
(Cameron laughing)
- Should we show the trophy, everybody?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
(lively music)
All right, well, we each have three plates
of carne asada tacos in front of us
and one is from
Mexicali Taco & Co.
- Hey!
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
There's Team Mexicali right there.
- We have one from Sonoratown.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
By the way, I lived there
for like two months.
I love Sonora, I did.
Great place to jump off rocks into water
and stuff like that.
And one taco from 1986.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
I'm dying to know what happened
to this person in 1986.
(friends laughing)
All right, up first is Mexicali Taco & Co.
Please take a look at this
little love letter for them.
- Hello, Drew, my name
is Chef Esdras Ochoa
and I am the partner and chef
here at Mexicali Taco & Co.
And I am so excited for
you to try the tacos today,
and we hope that you love
them as much as we do.
We started back in 2009
and we are proud to bring
the Norteno-style tacos here
to the city of Los Angeles.
That's what really sets us apart.
We specialize in flame broiled meats.
You get an option of
corn or flour tortilla.
My favorite is a carne asada
taco on a flour tortilla.
You put a little bit of salsa casera,
it's got a little bit of a kick
but it's focused on pure, pure flavor.
And then you get a little
bit of avocado sauce,
pickled red onions and fresh cabbage.
I love Mexicali-style taco,
and I'm confident that you will too.
Let the best taco win.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- And Esdras is in the
audience joining us.
Hello!
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
All right, anything we
should keep in our minds
as we put this in our mouths?
- Extra salsa!
- [Ross] Green or red, what do you think?
- [Drew] I'm going red.
- That salsa is bomb.
(Drew mumbling)
(Cameron laughing)
(Esdras laughing)
- These are so delicious,
Ross, what do you think?
- You guys, it's all about that
heat and then that tortilla.
I don't know what magic you put in there,
but can I please have the recipe?
The "Rossipe" I mean.
(Cameron laughing)
Delicious, there's a yummy
texture to the tortilla
that just brings it all together.
That is amazing.
- [Esdras] Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Kelsey and Malia, thoughts?
- It just melts in your mouth.
I don't wanna stop, I'm gonna keep eating.
(Kelsey laughing)
- It's so good.
- It's delicious.
- Thank you so very much,
your tacos are incredible.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
And it is so hard to pry
myself away from them.
- This is literally like
this is my dream job.
Thank you best friend for bringing me
to this moment in my life to be
a judge of tacos.
- [Ross] You're welcome.
- [Drew] Okay, you're next.
- Okay, I am next, I'm up, okay.
We're moving onto the next
contender, Sonoratown.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- A great place to jump off rocks.
- Amazing place to jump
off rocks, apparently.
Check this out.
- Hi, Drew, my name is Jennifer Feltham
and I'm the co-owner of Sonoratown
in Downtown, Los Angeles.
We're a Northern Mexican style tacoria.
My boyfriend, Teo, moved
here when he was a young kid
and couldn't find the style
of food that he grew up eating
in San Luis Rio Colorado
anywhere in Los Angeles.
So that inspired us to open our own place.
The name Sonoratown is taken
from a historic neighborhood
in Downtown, Los Angeles that
existed here in the 1850s.
What makes our food unique?
We make all of our own
flour tortillas in-house.
We are making about 2,000 tortillas a day.
We also bring in the best quality steak,
because Sonora is known for
having the best carne asada
in all of Mexico.
Our tacos are simple, but delicious.
You get a homemade flour tortilla,
freshly barbecued carne asada,
spicy Chile de Arbol salsa,
pureed avocado and cabbage.
Drew, I'm so excited to be able
to share our family recipes
with you today.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- And Jennifer is joining
us in the audience today.
- Hi, Jennifer!
- So excited to meet you guys
and share what we do with you.
- All right, everybody.
- Okay, here we go.
- Here we go.
- Ready, set, bite.
(Cameron mumbling)
(Drew mumbling)
(audience cheering)
How incredibly different
your guys's style is.
- Completely.
Oh my God.
But...
Yum!
- Yeah.
Kelsey, you had a big reaction.
What was that all about?
- That was a flavor explosion in my mouth!
(Kelsey laughing)
It was so delicious.
All the textures, and that
cream, is that the avocado?
- There's no cream in it.
It's just pureed avocado,
you get that sensation.
- That's amazing.
- So good.
- [Cameron] This is so yummy.
- Rossy, thoughts?
- I am obsessed with this taco.
It is so good.
It is salty and spicy,
but there is such freshness
that just pops through.
Well done.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- [Drew] And clearly I love your hometown.
- I'll see you at the restaurant.
- I'll see you on the rock.
- Okay, perfect, yes.
- All right, we're gonna go
to a quick commercial break,
but coming up, we have
one more taco to try
and then we're gonna declare our winner.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Welcome back!
It's our Battle of the Bites: Cali Tacos.
Now this is our besties hour,
so Kelsey and Malia are
also over there joining us
because they're besties.
(audience applauding)
By the way, how long
have you been besties?
- Six years, since we moved to
LA at the same time to dance.
- Well, we have been enjoying tacos,
we've already tried Mexicali Taco & Co.
and Sonoratown, and our final
contender is Tacos 1986.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Drew, my name is
Jorge Alvarez-Tostado,
people call me El Joy.
I'm one of the taqueros and
owners here at Tacos 1986.
We started off as a taco
stand in November, 2018,
on the corner of Highland
and Lexington in Hollywood,
and now we have five amazing stores.
This tacoria was inspired
by a Tijuana-style taco,
which is where me and my
partner, Victor, are from.
What makes our taco unique,
it's our handmade tortilla
that's followed by your choice of protein.
Our carne asada taco starts
with a handmade tortilla,
grilled steak, garnished with onion,
cilantro, guacamole, and salsa.
I'm the greatest taquero of all time,
bring on the competition.
(lips smacking)
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
- El Joy
is joining us, everybody.
What happened in 1986?
- That's the year I was born.
- Oh!
- I'm pretty.
Hold up, hold up, you
have to put the salsas
that are right next to
that plate right there.
It could be the green salsa
or, that's the chili salsa.
- Is that the hotter one?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, throw it in,
and then that one, right
there is a strawberry salsa.
- This one?
- That one right there.
- Strawberry salsa.
- The hottest.
- What is this?
- Get in my mouth!
- That's a chili oil salsa
made out of five different chilies.
Delicious.
- Get in my mouth!
- Here we go.
(audience laughing)
- Yum!
- Thank you so much.
- Kelsey and Malia, thoughts?
- I think the texture of
the tortilla is really nice
and there's a lot of brightness in it,
even though it feels like
very comforting and homey.
- Rossy?
- I want this taco to never, ever end.
This is so good.
- All right, just wanna say
to each and every one of you,
thank you for this privilege.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Growing up in California, you know,
we take tacos for granted
because they're everywhere.
It's really about the culture
that we share in California,
Southern California,
in particular with Mexico, our neighbors.
And we have to remember that
that food like really
has been such a big part
of all of our lives
and we wouldn't have it
without that culture,
without that country.
And I really just appreciate that culture.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- It is time to vote, but I
think before we do let's reveal
who our Twitter poll
chose, because we asked you
all to vote on your favorite
and the winning taco with 47%
was Tacos 1986.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
I know.
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
I love it.
Now, it is our turn and
I am gonna start it off.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
It kills me to say it
'cause I love them all,
but I'm gonna put this front and center.
- I'm gonna go for.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- Oh, Ross!
All right, Ross.
- All of these tacos were delicious
and I wanna thank you all
for turning our daytime talk
show into a daytime taco show.
(friends chuckling)
There can only be one winner
and I have to vote for.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Because of that tortilla.
- [Cameron] That tortilla!
- It's so good.
- It was so chewy and yummy.
- And the salsa's the bomb.
- [Malia] Let's stick with our choice.
- All right, Kelsey and Malia.
- So are you ready, Kelsey?
- Let's do it.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- I mean,
we've actually gotten
ourselves into a tie situation.
All right, so guess what?
Both of these restaurants
are gonna get a trophy.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Congratulations to all three restaurants
and thank you, Kelsey and
Malia, you guys are so awesome.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(lively music)